I think sometimes when you're like that
personality that's powerful like me
you've been there since day one I feel
like I'm a threat to certain girls I
don't know why because I personally
think that everybody has their own lane
the problem is don't you trying to cross
over in my lane and stay over there we
don't have a car crash I'm you saying
you're lying girl housewife is my baby
and I really do want to see it you know
stay around for 10 15 20 years if we can
okay Nene that is what you told us just
in November yeah but now we got to talk
rumors because there are rumors you may
be wanting to leave housewives or people
may be trying to phase you out what is
happening um I don't know about the
whole phase in that part actually I
asked ANVISA ask Kenya
why was she going around saying that and
I think Andy helped kind of clear that
up a little bit let's take a look at
what happened on watch what happens live
with Andy himself yes she would need to
ask Bravo why they're cutting her out of
mini ups so it's a season okay but
you're saying that she's being phased I
think she is she's fighting to stay on
the show do you have a word for your
reaction to that clip that girl is crazy
something is really wrong with her no
seriously you know I if it was my time
to go I absolutely have no problem with
that because the show has been good to
me I've been there since day one and I
opened up this door so can you big mouth
more could walk through it okay you're
an OG nene leakes I mean this franchise
is built on your shoulders and I know
that yes it was so what about her saying
that they're cutting you out of episodes
well how does she know I mean does she
she and production I mean I don't know I
don't know why she says the things that
she say but what I do know is for
whatever reason I don't know how it
sounds I don't know if it even sounds
great to even say but I think that she
would love for me to be gone so she
could be in her mind the head of the
show of the queen of the show or the one
that everyone is talking about with me
there it's very difficult for her to
have that kind of thing
so and I also think that if I leave the
show and can't use face on the show she
will be the demise of the show why do
you say that because she said she's a
nasty girl her attitude is nasty she's
not a cool girl not a girl she tries to
talk about the girls doesn't like me
none of them like her
I mean her attitude is saying but the
show is built in large part on drama
back in the day you and Kim used to go
at it so how do you differentiate
between what works and what doesn't then
well first of all when Kim and I had our
differences there's a difference between
Kim and I and me and Kim Kim and I had a
real friendship we were friends before
this show ever started and our kids were
friends Kenya I've never had a
friendship with her I've never had a
friendship with her she's always come
around and just wanted to like bicker
with me and I think she want to bicker
with me because it looks good in the
press that's all I could think of
because it's not that serious we don't
have any feelings towards each other we
could easily move on and I want you to
know this I tried to smooth things over
with her several times from texting her
to emailing her to extending olive
branches to her inviting her to anything
I had just anything because I just felt
like it was so unnecessary to continue
to argue for what what we arguing about
well here's the thing it does continue
you guys always deliver a sensational
television on it Lana I'm not gonna back
down I'm not I'm not gonna back down and
I think that's what she knows so I think
she knows she could get some drama for
me because I'm not gonna back down I'm
just you know III don't mind like I
don't want to argue every
like that's not what I want to do I'm on
a spiritual journey I have someone
that's guiding me a lot and this helped
me a lot I don't want to bicker every
day with these girls and I always feel
like no matter what I do is very hard
for them to forgive but they forgive
each other in five seconds all the time
and they've done worse things to each
other and I've ever done Tibet okay well
I want to know what you think of what
point you might have been pushed at in
this clip that we're about to see yeah
what let's watch the clip and I want to
know your thoughts on it what got you
there what's going through nene leakes
is mine they're um
I don't even know what was once in my
mind at that moment but what I do know
is I didn't spit on her but I sort of
kind of wished ahead I'm just gonna be
honest about that because I just think
some of the things that Kenya says is
really nasty and really dirty and I just
feel like girl you are just I you
probably need to be spit on you just
probably need to be and it may not sound
great but she probably needs to be spit
on and I have no sympathy for her I just
don't
so why does it look like you're spitting
on her in that clip because I do the act
right I ought to and I say the worst
thoughts on you like that so of course
she wanted to run with it and that's why
with me I don't care girl ride with it I
hope that I I mean I only wish that I
had spit on you girl
there's no follow-through there so
you've got the issues with Kenya but
like you said maybe no real friendship
there even Cynthia had a really real
friendship yes where are you guys at
right now I think we're in a better
place today then we were months ago we
will never be the same but I think that
we are better now we can be in the same
setting we can laugh we can talk you
know that kind of stuff but as far as I
was hanging out calling each other like
we used to
that will never happen again
why do you say that um hey I'm not
interested in it happening again and B I
just don't think it is healthy for
either one of us and I don't think that
our friendship will survive being on a
show together so I just don't think it's
it will work being on this show so what
about your intentions with the show
we've asked you about this before do you
plan to stick with Atlanta from here I
can't say what I would do what I say is
that my entire team and I every season
we always get together and talk about
what's best for me
so I I don't know what we would do I
don't know but what I do know is that I
don't want to continue to be in a
setting where I feel like they're being
very malicious towards me they meeting
the cat the cat reduction the cast I
also feel like you know if everybody's
human on this show and everybody makes
mistakes and I feel like I definitely
made mistakes but I also feel like my
mistakes are forgivable
and if they can forgive each other I
don't understand why is that they can't
forgive me for any little thing and the
whole thing that they're trying to hold
against me is last year last year my
husband had cancer and I was his
caretaker I dealt with so much last year
and I feel like I don't get a break for
that I don't get any sympathy for that
because of meaning and we never had
cancer in our home before so I feel like
everybody was like well last year my
girl ash I don't even know who I was
last year like I went through so much
last year all right well here's what I
love about you Nene no matter what you
go through you find a way to make us all
laugh you are the energy in the room you
light it all up and now you're doing
this comedy tour yeah el us what that is
bringing to your life so I obviously I
went out on my own comedy tour by myself
and I'm not a comic I just love to laugh
and I love to talk trash all right so I
would listen to your doctor at all
Damian it's all coming from a good place
so I wish in my agent and I said I'd
love to produce an all-female comedy
and they worked with me and I produced
this show of amazing women Loni love
Sherri Shepherd adele givens
B Simone Kym Whitley and I host the show
so I come in and out of each coming
these girls are fabulous they're amazing
our next stop is this Saturday in
Philadelphia
we're sold out with you guys and after
Philadelphia is Las Vegas so we still
have tickets there for Vegas amazing
there's such a good ladies night out it
sounds like great ladies they bring the
girls yeah I need to bring your mansion
that's talented women you have another
lab there great and why did you want to
do all-female I'm a girl I'm always here
for women I have a hole with an
entrepreneur group that I head it's
called ladies of success it's
entrepreneurial women that are around
the world we are all like-minded we
support each other and lift each other
level up together be sounding boys for
each other so I love that so I wanted to
do something for women I'm all girl
power and this is an ensemble you do see
these are all women we've never had an
issue before ever everybody is super
professional everybody is at work they
do their job they enjoy their job
another cab
[Music]